hey everyone and welcome back to this
episode of versus won 200 vs. 1 as you
can see we're still working from home
here at Jubilee working hard to bring
you guys awesome content nonetheless
though so thanks for tuning in and thank
you to our sponsor surf shark VPN you
probably know that VPNs are really vital
in keeping you safe online because they
keep you anonymous and you may know that
they help you access content regardless
of the country that you're in but you
may not know that surf shark VPN can
actually help save you money when you're
shopping online so stick around after
the episode I'll tell you more about
that you'll get a promo code from surf
shark VPN but first here is vs. 1 and
I'm admitting all in three-two-one
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Joe I am extremely nervous
today are do you picky about the kind of
people you date I don't really like to
show like too many girls to my mom or
anything like that the next girl that I
do talk to eventually kind of like Meg
I'm not super picky but I do know what I
like
gonna get ready okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I like someone who really had like my
similar taste in music as long as like
you listening to Drake we can buy them
in the car like you know the lyrics I
know the lyrics girl met Drake's
wife wait what hell serenade you this is
good
you don't like Drake I'm concerned yeah
I know some drink okay I do like to hit
the gym myself about like six days a
week and during this quarantine it kind
of sucks but yes someone who just likes
to stay active whether it's hiking or
you know riding a bike or even just
taking a walk with like your friends
[Music]
first someone over 21 just so we can
know enjoy the nightlife with each other
[Music]
fashion yeah I have like an acquired
taste for fashion so if you have like
the might Feliz or anything like that I
just it's just a no-go for me those are
like dinosaur shoes I do understand that
you can make great connections with
someone who is halfway across the world
but for me that's just not really what
I'm looking for I do believe there's a
higher being so I am Christian but as
long as you have an open mind to
everything and can kind of understand
where people are coming from like we
don't have to have the same background
but oh you believe in something that's
all that matters to me
[Music]
I love my family I'm eight sisters three
brothers and I'm literally hanging out
with them all the time so like as long
as like she's family-oriented that's
something I look forward to a lot my
preference is someone that's within the
arts that has interest in the arts
whether it's you know being creative
with graphic design or acting or
something musical background I also like
someone who's interested in the medical
field who like helping others we can
take care of someone how are you doing I
feel like you're nervous as soon as you
came on I was like oh my God he's so
cute it texted like three other girls in
the chat we were bonding over how cute
you are family about something he seemed
super social
I try to be once I graduate I want to
get into music photography I photograph
for like Chris Brown like pentatonix I
like wine tasting a lot were you going
that over there it's like we're the best
wine comes from right I actually I don't
drink which I mean I do but like I don't
I really love like cleaning my apartment
so relaxing I said like can I do my
laundry at your house and I'm like I
would love nothing more
this is my favorite thing on the planet
I love pizza we go on a pizza tour of LA
right we could do that we could do it
playing a bunch of different like fans
or like recording sessions i think you
know i'm literally learning to play the
piano like during coursing like I'm
making myself and everything that's
awesome okay how's it going okay it's
I'm watching like YouTube videos like
trying to figure attack my fingers are
hurting I love music I love making it
eerie music maybe one day that he loves
me hey no porn shark there we can come
take a class private lesson make sure
you go all the way to the top of the
pole I think my they I think they are I
think there was a perfect day to you is
having a good time but like people that
I enjoy because in like any situation
any part of the world and as long as you
have people there who are like we care
about like it doesn't really matter
okay Michelle that's so fun I hope you
find like the love your life your
marriage everything no you're totally
good you're an awesome guy and I hope
like I hope you find someone and all
these ladies are gorgeous so like you
have good options
yeah later Tori ok well that you are
going to now choose the person you would
like to go on a date with how are you
feeling Jonah
[Music]
I'll probably go with where I'm gonna go
with with Bianca I'm so sorry I mean
it's totally fine
like everyone was so pretty and so fun
so I don't mind making friends out of
this and you were super cute so I was
like y'all make it together it's great
oh it was like awkward most fun thing
I've ever done
I was just sitting back here like is
this a real like am I really doing this
it's finished it's pretty stressful
over 200 Gracie too strong
I've been fain yeah I just really liked
about me we can he know after this point
- yeah how did that feel that was
extremely nerve-wracking but it was an
unforgettable experience
what did you learn about your dating
preferences oh I think my spectrums
pretty broad and you have some kind of
corpse about myself and I'm figuring out
and I think I'm getting there a big
shout out to our director Paolo for that
episode 200 versus one making it our
largest episode of versus one ever and
of course I also want to say a big thank
you to our sponsor surf shark VPN here
are three things a surf shark VPN do for
you that are worth the price of
admission alone
number one it keeps you safe when you're
browsing the web and it keeps you
anonymous which prevents data mining and
make sure that you're not a target of
identity theft online number two it
allows you to access content regardless
of where you are in the world especially
content that's stuck behind a geo
blocking wall of sorts so you may notice
that sometimes if you're traveling
abroad you try to watch Netflix you
can't do it
surf shark UPN will solve that problem
if you're in the UK for example you can
set your location to us and watch your
us shows the last favor think of mine
that surf shark PPN does for you is it
actually helps you save money a lot of
people don't know this but sometimes
businesses actually charge more
depending on where you are in the world
so for example if you're in the US and
you're shopping for flights from the
European carrier they may charge you
like 10 to 20 percent more just because
you're in the US with surf shark VPN you
can set your country to that European
country and shop like a local it's
really really awesome use the link in
the description below for 85% off and
three months free when you use the promo
code jubilee again use the promo code
jubilee for 85 percent off and three
months free of surf sharp median as
always thanks for watching stay safe
stay healthy and we'll see you next time